foreign
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
and Sony has just released their trailer
for Craven the hunter now what's really
interesting is I don't think they were
actually supposed to release this
trailer today however the trailer did
end up getting leaked and I originally
wasn't going to show any footage however
not too long ago Sony Pictures Canada
officially released the trailer on their
YouTube channel you can check it out
there of course we're going to go
through it in this video as well we're
gonna break down what exactly this movie
is about and some cool twists that they
have done to Craven the Hunter and I
gotta say this movie actually does look
pretty good and keep in mind that this
movie is going to be rated R so this
trailer is actually pretty intense I'm
pretty sure this is a red band trailer
with a green band trailer coming out
some other time and edit I just finished
recording this video I looked back on
YouTube Sony Pictures has officially
released the official trailer for this
the red band trailer so that is what we
are breaking down in this video the
first official teaser that we got for
the movie we're going gonna break it
down frame by frame so if you love
Marvel and you want to stay up to date
on the latest news be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell so at
first we start off with Craven in a big
city and it seems like his senses are
kind of going off or he is visualizing
what he is about to do we see this
moving van going across the street he is
visualizing attacking it and then he
runs leaps through a window busting it
several stories high lands on the ground
Barefoot and chases down his hunt his
prey this van and he catches up to it
and he manages to rip the door off
doesn't open the handle simply rips the
door from its hinges at the top plus not
to mention he is on one side of the van
at one point a car is coming and is
about to hit him and he does some
acrobatic stunts to get around to the
other side barely facing him him holding
on the entire time once he rips open the
door someone immediately tries to shoot
at him in which he quickly defends
himself ends up grabbing that person and
he gets his pray the Hunt is done for
him now this opening scene is meant to
show us a couple of things one is how he
is the ultimate Hunter he literally did
all this Barefoot he ran and chased down
on foot a van ripped open the door and
killed this guy without using any type
of weapons at all so it's meant to show
us that he is the ultimate Hunter but at
the same time we hear a voice throughout
this entire scene which is the voice of
Russell Crowe who plays his father in
this his words are my son never show
Mercy they are prey we are predators now
when he says this it ends up on a scene
where they killed what looks to be some
type of a kangaroo or some other type of
large game beast and Craven seems to be
feeling kind of bad that the Beast is
dead he didn't want to kill this beast
and we also see this in another scene as
well but first to finish who his father
is his father is clearly the head of
some big organization that is a type of
mercenary or bounty hunters and what
they want us to see here is that his
father is ruthless Russell crows
character is ruthless he's the head of
this organization he is a bounty hunter
himself he even tells them that their
mother died Craven and his brother he
feels No Remorse whatsoever for it but
Craven says it's your fault because you
sent her away and again no remorse he
says yeah well she was weak she was weak
in the head and this is where they show
us kind of the strain in the
relationship between Craven and his
father which ultimately leads to him
going against him but we'll get to that
in just a second we continue to learn
more about his father's business where
he asks his son if he knows what he does
do you know my business in which it
shows him killing a lot of different
people he says power is about strength
if you show weakness you will give our
enemies an opening then it shows us an
incredibly cool scene and I actually
love that they did this they show Craven
out with his father and the company
hunting they come across a lion and
again you can tell Craven does not want
to kill this animal he seems to like
animals doesn't want to kill them and
that is going to be a premise in this
story that he doesn't actually hunt
animals he hunts humans more on that but
he kind of hesitates he does end up
shooting the lion but the lion ends up
attacking him we do hear him yell run he
is most likely yelling to his brother
probably the only person that he really
cares about this because we know he
doesn't truly care about his father and
the lion maims him and cuts him open a
lot and bites into him but since Craven
did shoot him the lion is bleeding and
some of the Lion's blood gets into
Craven it falls right into one of the
teeth holes that the lion made in
Craven's body and this apparently is
where he gets his enhanced superhuman
strength speed stamina all that good
stuff from now this is not how it is in
the comics in the comics he takes a
serum that in the comics is what gives
him his enhanced strength and slows the
aging process for him however I gotta
say I do kind of like this origin that
they have created now in this movie a
little bit better it's kind of cool
because they say that he can use animals
to help him track and if he doesn't hunt
animals this is a great story of why he
doesn't hunt animals but he actually
uses them to help him hunt humans now if
you want to know more about Craven the
hunter about his comic Origins you can
check out my buddies at
comicbookdirect.com
they have created a website and company
that makes comic book shopping the
easiest it can possibly be they deliver
Comics straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and they'll ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now again this change is
actually really cool since he got a drop
of the Lion's blood inside of his own
blood he can now kind of communicate
with other animals and they can help him
track his prey and based off of the
couple of scenes that we see here
immediately after this it looks like he
is hunting down people who are hunting
animals now of course that's just one
part of it of course he's also going to
hunt down mercenaries and groups like
his father's organization but it does
seem like since he can't communicate
with animals he is also trying to
protect them as well and they work
together which is really cool that's
also going to tie him some really cool
Spider-Man stuff down the road and we do
even get a spider scene which we'll talk
about in just a bit now he does talk
about his father he says his father puts
evil into the world and I take it out I
gotta address the action in this because
it is absolutely insane and I'm not one
that enjoys Gore too much but these
scenes are pretty epic and pretty
graphic stabbing people in the throat
stabbing people in the faces at one
point in time he bites one person's nose
off and kind of spits it at the camera
he puts a bear trap on some person's
head this guy is going off now in the
comics Craven doesn't like to use guns
or bows he prefers to hunt with his bare
hands and it looks like in this he
doesn't like to use guns or bows but he
is a big fan of knives and other gadgets
like air traps also not to mention he
uses other animals as well now the next
scene is rather important because we see
him speaking again probably after a long
time to his brother it looks like his
brother kind of got out of his father's
organization somehow and this is most
likely the first time that he has met
with Craven in a pretty long time Craven
seemingly tells him what he is doing who
he has become but his brother says well
now you're just like our father just
another man hunting for a trophy however
of course it is different because
Craven's trophy is his father he wants
to stop his father bring him down and
sort of get payback on how he treated
him and killing his mother and
everything like that so he's slowly
stopping his father's organization by
killing all of his men but the ultimate
trophy for him in this movie is going to
be his father we see some other really
awesome scenes of Craven jumping into
the air grabbing a pole throwing it
through a helicopter and killing the
pilot a lot of scenes of him killing
other people stabbing them in the neck
and then a big scene where he finally
comes face to face with his father again
his father goes to hit him but he stops
him from hitting him and says that you
don't get to do that anymore then we see
a scene where Craven finds the fur coat
the iconic Craven for best and it
honestly looks pretty dang good one of
the final scenes is in an office a
person comes in asking for Mr teglund
probably works for him possibly his
assistant Craven spins around in the
chair though having already taken out Mr
teglund the assistant asks where is he
and he says just standing in him he's
already killed him in a pool of blood is
dripping onto this person's feet and
which then he dies at the hands of
Craven as well so this shows us that
Craven really like his father taught him
shows no mercy he has a list of people
he is going to hunt and he is going to
kill them all and anybody else that
stands in the way and probably also
kills anybody else that is associated
with these people he has a list clearly
he has a little Journal that we see him
right in and he's Crossing off names
these people most likely are associated
with his father somehow or are
associated with some crime in some way
shape or form or perhaps they are animal
poachers people who go out and Hunt big
game animals and now he kills them
because the animals are his family and
in one of these last scenes we even see
that he has become kind of an animal
himself he is running across the walls
jumping on people jumping back on the
walls and just absolutely running
through people here so Craven himself is
kind of an animal and this most likely
does come from the Lion's blood getting
inside his own now one scene to talk
about that is extremely important is the
scene where he's in the Woods by a tree
and spiders are all around him falling
down this might be the scene where he
gets kind of a fear of spiders perhaps
some of them bite him perhaps he gets
kind of sick and it doesn't seem like he
can communicate with them at all or
control them in any type of way like he
can other animals which makes sense
because they are not mammals perhaps you
can only communicate with mammals in the
movie but what's interesting is he
clearly looks pretty scared here and
this could be the start of his
interaction with a future Spider-Man in
the comics Craven wants to hunt
Spider-Man because he sees him as the
ultimate big game prize and this could
kind have lead up to that as well since
he might have a fear of spiders and he
can't control them that would mean
Spider-Man would kind of be the ultimate
hunt for him so once he finds out that
there's a superhero out there that has
the abilities of a spider and is
literally called Spider-Man that could
trigger something inside of him to go
and try to hunt Spider-Man and that's
how we could get our Craven versus
Spider-Man film whether or not that will
take place in the Sony spiderverse or
the Marvel Cinematic Universe we're
unsure at this point but we are
definitely looking forward to that now
the last scene kind of teases who the
main villain is going to be of this film
besides Craven's father and that is
Rhino and this is going to be a very
different Rhino than we've seen from
Sony this is not a mechanical Rhino this
is indeed going to be sort of a
biological Rhino a mutated Rhino alexky
systovich taking a serum turning himself
into a beast a giant Man Rhino so Rhino
is going to be pretty much the main
villain of this film of course his
father is a villain as well but as far
as the the theatrical side and a big
epic fight going down it's going to be
between him and Rhino and his father who
knows if he's going to kill him in this
film we'll have to wait and see but
clearly he does confront his father in
this as well but I can't wait to see
Rhino I hope he's done correctly this
whole trailer looks pretty dang good and
I actually am really really excited for
this movie now but hey go ahead and let
us know your thoughts about it in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
beep